in verità vi dico se non vi convertirete
e non diventerete come bambini non
entrerete nel regno dei cieli
matteo 18 3 voglio la spiega da gesù che
forse nella vita di tutti i giorni
qualcosa di sbagliato c'è perché a meno
che tu non sia un bambino e non sia
giocando al parco dire o fare ciao ciao
uno sconosciuto è follia ma farlo via
facebook è normalità
siamo tutti amici su facebook
vuoi sapere quanti di voi hanno un
profilo facebook
alzate le mani senza paura alzate le
mani alzate le mani alzate le mani
perché rimanete con le mani alzate non è
possibile che sono dieci persone su 100
non al profilo facebook
rimanete rimanete con le mani alzate
rimanete con le mani alzate voi che
avete profilo facebook
rimanete con le mani alzate quanti fra
voi che avete profilo facebook avete
detto nella realtà viso avviso ciao come
stai come ti senti come va a tutti ma
dico tutti gli amici facebook che avete
ok praticamente quindi siamo tutti amici
su facebook e nella realtà non ci
caliamo e anch'io sono su facebook mi
chiamo gabriele camelo come sono stato
presentato il mio cognome un dramma
dico sempre che è come carmelo senza la
r comunque la gente si sbaglia lo stesso
mio padre mi dice che prima di nascere
stavo dentro una stella
io immaginavo questo globo scuro i 10
metri quadri in cui mi annoiavo da solo
senza avere nulla da fare quindi poi
quando sono nato
ha incominciato ad essere un po troppo
estroverso in questo forte bisogna in
relazione così forte che se io potessi
andrei a ciascuno di voi e vi chiederei
di scambiare due chiacchiere di avere un
po di umanità con cui purtroppo sono su
un palco sede tanti ma credo che questo
bisogno di relazione facciamo un po
parte di tutti scambiare due chiacchiere
vi chiederei che cosa pensate dell'amore
o di raccontare nella vostra fissazione
ad esempio io sono fissato che il foglio
del roto dalla carta igienica delle
catene dalla parte esterna rispetto al
muro
io cambio i rotoli di carta igienica
nelle case degli altri mi danno fastidio
c'è qualcuno che conosce questa
fissazione che un mio amico che in sala
che lui lo fa apposta quando viene a
casa mia mi cambia il rotolo io entro in
bagno e provo un fastidio atroce che io
parlerei di queste cose con ciascuno di
voi
purtroppo non è possibile c'è questa
questa differenza fra mondo reale e
mondo e mondo virtuale
scusate mi sono così ma sto cercando di
recuperare il tempo perso dentro la
stella ho passato un periodo molto
brutto nel 2015
questo è un post che ho scritto nel
giorno di pasquetta
vi leggo solo l'inizio perché sono
logorroico e questo è dovuto al fatto
che stavo dentro una stella ha dovuto
recuperare il tempo c'è tra eccetera e
pasquetta 2015 scrivo all'inizio
facebook oggi si riempie di tavole
imbandite tavole imbandite significa
cura vino buon cibo 10 assieme famiglie
unite
ecco questa è la mia tavola è triste e
triste io non so perché dio mi abbia
dato questa tavola ma è da questa tavola
che provengo io non ho una famiglia alle
spalle e non è colpa né di mia madre né
di mio padre è successo è così e non me
la sento in un luogo pubblico di
raccontare il perché ma io non ho una
tavola imbandita di nessuno e colpa è
mia madre sta in un posto mio padre sta
in un altro mio fratello pure i mezzi
pure nei cugini anche mentre i nonni
sono in cielo molti
un pezzo non è cosa di oggi io sono
cresciuto così con questo mostro addosso
che ha un nome che è solitudine lo porto
ancora addosso è un mostro mi sta dentro
questo mostro in realtà per assurdo non
è solo perché sono altro mostro che si
chiama senso di non valere anche se
forse sembra sicuro non lo so anche se
vedete mi sto muovendo avanti indietro e
sento che la voce si increspa in realtà
io penso quindi cosa che io faccio la
sto facendo sbagliata e anche adesso mi
sento un po in crisi sento che forse
sbaglierò
ho la mano che mi trema è la cosa
peggiore non solo che io penso di fare
cose sbagliate e che penso proprio io di
essere sbagliato e quindi con questi due
mostri che farsi ogni giorno ci sono due
cose o uno rimane schiacciato questi due
mostri oppure uno fa come ha fatto credo
ciascuno di voi arrivando qui stamattina
un arriva parcheggio della macchina va
l'ingresso trova tutto chiuso e una
portineria vuota che si intravede un
cancello chiuso e uno dice ok che faccio
forse non equa
risalgo in macchina me ne vado un attimo
di crisi poi in realtà se ce la fa così
come ciascuno di voi ce l'ha fatta ma il
tastino che sia un tastino di suoni e
che aprano ecco quella è la porta chiusa
sono i miei mostri ho deciso di non
rimanere rimanere là fuori ma ho deciso
di andare a oltre prendere per mano i
miei mostri e credo che i dolori siano
come ingredienti di pozioni magiche
messe assieme ad altre cose positive si
possono creare delle cose bellissime
quindi ho preso la mia solitudine il mio
senso in un valere li ho presi per mano
gli o mischiati assieme alla grande
voglia di rivalsa la voglia di fare la
voglia di reagire voglia di reagire
voglia reagire e ho creato questo questo
questo
sono alcune foto tratte da una pagina
facebook che si chiama moon in armonia
appunto che molti some sento siciliani
significa dai forza su svegliati da una
pagina tramite la quale organizziamo
eventi nella realtà dove permettere alle
persone di non guardarsi dei profili su
instagram ma di guardarsi nella realtà
di scambiare emozioni dirsi ciao come
stai come va magari abbracciarsi tornare
bambini giocare a ruba bandiera o andare
insieme in un locale passare un
aperitivo assieme e guardarsi negli
occhi e non tramite foto profilo quindi
si organizzano eventi fra persone che
non si conoscono creiamo dei gruppi
omogenei per età e per mettiamo le
persone di diventare amiche nella
semplicità questa è stata la mia maniera
di reagire al dolore non l'ho fatta da
sola nasce questa idea da assieme
all'altro mio amico di qualche anno fa
il mio migliore amico davide con cui ci
lamentavamo in continuazione di questo
modo difficile di entrare in relazione
semplice autentica tutto è nato e lei
non lo sa da un ex compagna del liceo
perché andando in giro per il centro di
palermo io questo ragazzo abbiamo
incontrato per caso questa ragazza che
non vedevamo da tempo
quindi io mi sono avvicinato e
contentissimo di rivederla
di averla riconosciuta mi sono
identificato lei mi ha guardato metto è
e quindi e quindi me ne sono tornato
indietro da davide si può cadere non ci
puoi credere mi ha praticamente risposto
malissimo
quella sera io e davide di fronte erano
botti dei prosecco una fetta di grana
padano
abbiamo detto basta cioè basta
riportiamo umanità in questo mondo tutti
diventano amici su facebook poi in
realtà siamo tutti distanti non è
possibile un controsenso basta
lamentarci facciamo qualcosa
questo è quello che noi abbiamo fatto un
lo scorso natale
alla vigilia ero solo con mia mamma e
come tutti i natali non avevo con chi
passarlo
è un momento molto duro e triste
tutti lo passano in famiglia era moglie
mia mamma da soli grazie all'idea di
un'altra ragazza che frequenta muni
abbiamo scelto di organizzare una cena
della vigilia in una trattoria invitando
tutte quelle persone un po come noi in
difficoltà senza avere una grande
compagnia con cui passare la vigilia di
natale
abbiamo invitato tramite la caritas
anche dei senzatetto più altre persone
comuni come noi e abbiamo preso una
trattoria
eravamo una ventina di persone abbiamo
passato la vigilia di natale assieme
scambiandoci anche dei regali
penso che sia stato il più bel natale di
una vita
ora io non so se c'è un dio allah o
qualsiasi altro dio che sta lassù
se ci farà entrare nel regno dei cieli
come diceva matteo nel vangelo
però sono sicuro che magari guarderà
tutta questa cosa con dolcezza e se c'è
una resurrezione
se siano resurrezione credo che sia
proprio questa non quella che avverrà
dopo la morte se uno crede ma credo che
sia questa stare qui su questa terra e
zampetta re zompettare saltare giocare
sui propri dolori creando cose belle
grazie
[Applauso]